historical mass vaccination has started
across the eu
to curb the covet 19 pandemic in an
unprecedented global approach
the european commission is centralizing
vaccine contract negotiations and
purchases for the bloc
imagine a calculus
in total some 2 billion doses have been
secured by the eu
in line with national strategies the
first people to receive the kovit 19
vaccines are the elderly
the clinically vulnerable and medical
staff
while members of the european parliament
fully support the eu strategy
they are calling for more openness on
how the commission deals with vaccine
contracts
authorizations and supplies
transparency
meps have been allowed to see one of the
vaccine contracts in secure reading
rooms
but many important clauses in the
agreement have been taken out
to date two vaccines have been
authorized by the european medicines
agency
and an authorization for a third one is
expected at the end of january
meps want more insight into the
decision-making process
parliament says the best way to avoid
uncertainty and misinformation
surrounding covid19 vaccines
is through transparency and openness